je réponds à caroline qui n'ont rien
email en dix ans fait toujours
l'interview psya défi ben non je la fais
un garçon et c'est beaucoup plus
excitant
est ce que vous êtes parano par exemple
j'aime abénex quand il a lancé son fils
me l'a dit la chasse aux beineix est
ouverte
alors tout le monde à les mélanger pas
de chasse aux beineix et personne ne l'a
vu encore donc c'est un peu de la parano
est ce que vous vous êtes un peu comme
ça à croire que tout le monde vous
déteste c'est tout non non non non je
pense pas non non non mais par rapport à
jean jacques je pense que il ya des gens
qui l'attendait au cou avec un couteau
quand même avait quand même c'est que
c'est vrai mais non je sais quelle
raison la main je pense au contraire
même qu'il a été très utile très très
spirituel paramore d'accord à cette
phrase excuse et de ce qu'ils au nom
claustro oui c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que je ne fais pas de théâtre
et
même en gymnase ces prix le gymnase
s'est pris pour trois ans je vous êtes
exhibo oui non pas trop
vous n'êtes pas exhibo non pas tant que
ça magnéto serge vous êtes nympho oui
pas forcément que j'ai à megève me
tapait beaucoup de femmes mais j'aime
bien refaire plusieurs fois vous allez
maintenant ça c'est dur à ces fétiches
au bape anna rothwell à chaque foyer
salle au nom pas bon non vous aimez pas
d'enseignement au mot vais-je été violée
à l'âge de 13 ans par un pédophile donc
avant c'est vrai j'ai du mal
ah oui dans ce cas là je savais pas ça
mais non personne ne le savait pas
c'était aussi la première fois que je le
dis je suis sur le recul
c'est pas c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
c'est bien c'est courageux de dire ça
si vous applaudissez trop ça va
encourager les pédophiles en même temps
ces courageuses qui fait et ils se
conservent à doser quoi voulez qu'on
arrête là parce que non pourquoi non
têtards d'eau oui ça m'arrive ouais
c'est honteux
comment peux tu mon coco non ayrault non
adamo oui mais enfin il ya bien
longtemps
bernardo secchi 2.0 sur mu et de nador
bien si vous êtes disque au nom et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus